my ability to only be comfortable in
massive chaos has been my biggest asset
as an entrepreneur like I would never
take a note like that scares the piss
out of me what these three people are
doing right now
dwelling on what you up on is the
quickest way for the next thing not to
work take life by its throat do
something stopping scared the motivation
whattcha top ten with belief nation
what's that belief nation it seven my
one word is believe and I believe in you
I believe you have Michael Jordan level
talent add something and I want you to
find it embrace it and make a difference
using it so let's get your motivation to
attend and get you believing in you grab
a snack and chew in today's lessons from
a man who went from being born in the
Soviet Union and hustlin as a kid
selling flowers and baseball cards to
expand in his family's wine business and
then founding vaynermedia with the
current ambition to be one of the most
prolific entrepreneurs of his generation
he's Gary Vaynerchuk and here's my take
on his top 50 rules for success
enjoy
[Music]
alright let's kick things off with rule
number one bet on your strengths you
need to bet on your strengths and don't
give a [ __ ] about what you suck at
you're gonna way too many people in this
room are gonna spend the next 30 40
years of their lives trying to check the
boxes other things that they're not as
good at and that you're gonna waste a
load of time and lose I highly recommend
auditing yourself or if you have no
empathy or EQ or self-awareness then
find somebody in your family or
friendship that does and let them tell
you who you are and once you believe
that either for yourself or someone else
told you go directly all chips all into
that because that is the only possible
way in my opinion watching from the
outside that is limited phrase that is a
very highly likely way of over-indexing
because the truth is if you want to be
an anomaly you've got to act like one
you know like and so that's it that's
what I got so thanks for having me
rule number two work how do you get
money to do what you love you don't
write I lost a shitload of money when I
started doing what I loved what you do
is you position yourself to succeed so
for example if you're doing something
else and you and you want to do this
thing you love you do it after hours you
work 9 to 6 you get home you kiss the
dog and you go to town right I mean you
start building your equity in your brand
and whatever you're trying to accomplish
after hours you everybody has time stop
watching lost
that's a good overheard right that was a
good overheard so you know what I mean I
mean if you want this if you want bling
bling if you want to buy the Jets if you
want to do work that's how you get it
rule number three put business in
perspective make questions
I'm entrepreneurs very great but not all
days are great seeing a company so what
are your tips and tricks for tough days
I think there's massive confusion around
entrepreneurship entrepreneurship sucks
I mean it's lonely it's high-risk I mean
I can't live without it but it's like a
bad boyfriend right a girlfriend right
like like it's there's a ton of bad days
being an entrepreneur
not to mention 98% of entrepreneurial
ventures are gonna fail so there's gonna
be a really bad day in your future you
know hopefully not for you or any of you
you know for me I don't you know I think
this is a very personal question I think
it's how you're wired I'm so all-in
entrepreneur I prefer the pain I think
one of the reasons I love the Jets so
much is because they bring me so much
pain you know I I love the climb to me
the setback is exciting I love when
something goes wrong it's where I shine
the most but that's not for everybody
right I mean it could be very difficult
and when you start affecting your life
and your loved ones and all the other
things it can get real nasty to me the
way I handle things even though the few
rare days when I really struggle I take
a real step back and make pretend that
somebody called me and told me that my
mother or daughter were killed and I
know that's very dark and I apologize
but it's really what I do I literally am
able to at my deepest most struggling
moment within business take a step back
and remind myself that I could make a
trillion dollars tomorrow on Bitcoin and
and if something bad happened to the
people I love the most that it would
mean nothing and it very consistently
rewires me very quickly
I just put business in perspective at
the end of the day you know it's it's
money for me it's not really money it's
my legacy so I get hurt by it a little
bit more
but uh yeah
I mean it's you know I put in
perspective its money and you know what
up until I had a daughter even while I
was married up until when I had Nisha
four years ago I secretly wanted to lose
all my money I had this weird twisted
dark fantasy of losing everything just
to rise again like a phoenix and remind
you my rule number four execute your
ideas my assistants got a great thing
now in this once in every four months
somebody sends an email saying I've got
a huge startup that I want you to invest
in but you've got to sign this NDA
right which literally every time gets an
email back that says [ __ ] you right and
and the reason is I'm a humongous
believer that ideas are shaped and that
executions the game right we've all got
ideas everybody's got ideas doing ideas
we all have here we can probably sit
here for the next two hours draw them
all out record them and predict the next
78 great startups over the next nine
years and so I think the thing that is
another theme in entrepreneurship is
there is way too much fodder brought to
the idea Hoover was magic cab three
years earlier
uber is not an idea uber existed it's
called magic cab but the guys that
execute it sucked
so they lost so I think you know if
there's any level of romance left in
this room about your idea I'd like to
suffocate it because I think the actual
situation is what you actually do with
it
rule number five don't overlook
storytelling you know the reason I feel
storytelling is the most underrated
skill in business is because it doesn't
get talked about a whole lot and I don't
think that people realize it's happening
when it's happening
and most of all I don't think that many
people really good at it select when I
watch a Steve Jobs keynote about a new
product I don't care about the new tech
I don't care about the iPad or the
iPhone I cared about the way he's
presenting it you know when when I see
David Blaine this is a magician if you
ever pay attention to what he's doing
he's story telling you the whole way and
net it's a big kick so if you understand
what the consumer wants then you
backtrack and you tell the story to get
them emotionally there that's how things
sell that's marketing there's a very big
difference between marketing and sales
and so the reason I think that people
are missing why things succeed is
because of storytelling and I think it's
overlooked I think people look at the
X's and O's and the black and the white
but I think storytelling when done right
takes a product that should have sold
100 million dollars worth of stuff and
it sells a billion dollars worth of
stuff rule number six care about your
customers in nineteen in 2001 it snowed
in New Jersey on December 23rd which was
one of the busiest days of the year
typically December 23rd is the busiest
day of the year in a liquor store and a
woman called us we just started shipping
and her case of behringer White
Zinfandel wasn't delivered first of all
I appreciate the people that know what
behringer white sin is good job the
entire case by the way 15 pack the
entire 15 pack case cost $45 we're doing
about forty thousand dollars an hour in
the store she calls I find out about it
somehow it was buzzing I was on the
floor selling I am the premiere salesman
on the floor as you can imagine I find
out about it and we're debating what to
do she needs it for her Christmas dinner
I grab the case throw it in my car and
drive to Bergen County to deliver it it
takes me two and a half hours to
complete the whole thing the woman was a
hundred and ninety four years old
we didn't have a lot of lifetime value
on the back end there she looked like
Yoda and the best part was I delivered
it all pumped with myself and she said
great and close the door
awesome everybody especially my dad who
was pissed that I left because all the
customers that came in asking for me or
that I could have sold everybody who's
baffled I can't tell you what the ROI of
driving through the snow in my car to
deliver a case of $45 pink shot to a
woman that looked like Yoda was but I
can tell you this over the next two to
three years that story became the
foundation of how we treated every
single customer it became our
competitive edge and those are the
things that matter to me I love black
and white data I'm obsessed with it the
day when the nerd beat me I understood
that the nerds beat me and I respect the
living out of data conversion funnels
all that but I'm telling you right now
that there are way too many running
businesses today with this and not
enough people running businesses with
this
and again I swear on my life I am not
Mother Teresa and I far from run my
business just on this but I'm telling
you right now the reason I amassed my
following the reason why I continued to
retain it is because my percentage of
this far outweighs every thought in this
room I mean it that's how I feel and
that's how I try to roll every day and I
promise you if you were able to figure
out how to afford how to afford the
allocation of this in your business more
your long-term value will be
dramatically higher your long-term
business success will be dramatically
higher your grandparents your
great-grandparents built businesses
based on this it's how we built the
whole thing we got really lean and mean
when we went to the suburbs and big box
stores are all we cared about was
dollars and it's great and the data
matters and continue to use it and use
this tool and understand it but I'm
asking you one final thing when you go
home if this talk meant anything and by
the way I fundamentally believe only
three of you were gonna act on this talk
I do because what I talk about is
ridiculously hard and massively
frustrating and takes forever you know
like everything that's good in life if
you do anything because of this keynote
there's only one thing I ask you to do
because as any as I got I'm a practical
here's what I want from you when you go
home look yourself in the mirror and
audit everything you and your business
do I promise you that if you audit from
top to bottom of expenses and effort and
time and energy and payroll and all that
if you audit all of it even the best of
us even the InBev's
which is the company that bought
Budweiser they built their whole
business on like printing on both sides
of the paper and all that work even the
most efficient ones of us are doing 20%
dumb job if you take that 8% that 13%
that 16% of dumbshit that you're doing
paying that person that's not bringing
any cultural value to your business
having that contract that you've just
been in you just renew because your
busiest
whatever the [ __ ] you're doing if you
take any piece of that percentage and
you apply it to giving a [ __ ] about your
customer it will be better for your
business going forward because for the
first time since we all lived in small
pounds where your reputation was the
complete backbone of how you did
business for the first time because
technology is bringing us back together
in a small town for the first time being
good and caring and following up matters
if matters how about doing something
random act of kindness for a current
customer not the ones that unsubscribed
or left you know how you always do nice
when they're going how about while
you've got them reallocate your thought
process I'm telling you because the
tools that the is the umbrella of this
organism en't are getting so good so
good you know what that means all that
shit's about to become a commodity
emotional e.q is going to dominate
business over the next decade and I
implore you start paying attention and
oh by the way I'll leave you with this
you know what the best part is it feels
good thank you rule number seven stick
to your DNA the ability to adjust is the
entire game like I'm so proud that I
changed my mind every day my dad used to
get so pissed when I was building wine
library he would always be like he's
like he would say like three months ago
you said Ricky was gonna be the best
employee I'm like I changed my mind he
fire him or or he's like you said
sparkling wine was important now you
just eliminated it from the piece bottom
like I changed my mind like my ability
to only be comfortable in massive chaos
has been my biggest asset as an
entrepreneur like I would never take a
note like that scares the piss out of me
what these three people are doing right
now right and so now you know now that
may work for them and I'm not like back
to the opening statement like you need
to do you like some plenty of people
that make a fuckload more money than me
and one bigger take notes the key the
key though the key is way too many
people are doing like here's a good one
you know what really pissed me the
Popoff I'm completely driven by like
happiness and like I'm crippled by like
chaos like you know vaynermedia which is
not 500 people update your
[Laughter]
vaynermedia is like completely dictated
by like I'm a dictator of HR like all I
care about is the atmosphere all I care
about is how people intern all I care
about is like how people roll like I
think I've fired four most talented
smartest people that have worked for me
because if you don't know how to play
with the other boys and girls you're out
because I suffocate under you know
conflict and negativity and like
nobody's better than me so you got to go
so what really pissed me off in tech
world was when Steve Jobs his book came
out when he was dying when it was all
about Steve three or four years ago I
literally watched a lot of my tech
startup friends start being like a to
their staff because jobs was tough
everybody fell into the romance stuff
like I have this big vision and I'm
gonna be a like Steve Wright and I
thought that was really interesting for
me to watch that half decade like
literally watching people I know and
then watching them act differently
because the status or the icon of the
moment and you see a lot of that and so
like that is probably the energy I'm
trying to bring to this class today
which is you can look at like how people
roll and like it's great to admire and
things of that nature but it's so damn
important to stick to like your DNA
right and like what you're good at and
to recognize that you need to surround
yourself whether it's your co-founder or
whether it's the people that work for
you like all I do is hire the people
that are the opposite of me that bring
the other value that bring me the
ability to remember what that meeting
was about and go make sure it happens
you know like whatever it may be right
and so I think that's another thing that
I would HIGHLY recognize rule number
eight do the things that matter I
delegate everything that I think is not
the single most important things in the
world and then I might go manage the
things that I think are the most
important things in the world luckily
for me hence why I've been able to build
big companies I don't think most things
matter so I don't think I'm any
different than anybody else
I actually think everybody is a
delegator and a micromanager
I just think that my radar of what's
important is different
yes we need to do something with that
that's the guys that's it right there
I'm just like you were all the same we
all delegate we all micromanage the
differences I don't think most things
matter and what do I mean by that as I'm
trying to think about somebody watching
this for the first time instead of
alluding to like people that have
watched forever most things don't matter
like it like I don't know like just
bladder that's what it means like you
know like if I was like I don't know I
don't think lighting matters as much as
directly I just don't think things
matter like I don't think like one
client that's gonna put us out of it
like I don't think one employee's gonna
kill our atmosphere like like like III
don't think a lot of things matter I
don't think like like a misspelling in a
deck is something that really matters to
a lot of people in my comedy it just
doesn't matter to me I just don't think
so guys guys I don't think we're gonna
lose a count because we put the eye
before the e and if we do them idiots I
don't think not being I don't think not
wearing shoes in an establishment is you
know the biggest thing in the world
clearly if you've watched Ellie be won
some people do and guess what I do not
judge do not judge everybody's allowed
to do their thing it's just like
parenting I will never speak my
parenting I talk about it but it's very
holistic like this is what I do not what
I'm telling you to do this is me but
like so ultimately I think that I'm both
like everybody in the world I just think
that I deem what's most important at a
very very high level on things that most
people you know what a lot of you are
commenting about my five-minute meetings
most of you because you're part of my
community you think it's great a lot of
comments in YouTube and Facebook I'm
like oh I like dailyvee because Gary
spends five that's nice
I've one comment I work in a small and
I'll ever said this is gonna see this
and be like holy crap he reads
everything I work it I've worked at
small companies where the boss didn't
even know my name you know what I mean
like this is cool but do you know many
people think it's stupid
I have a lot of people in my life to
think that I'm very busy and I have a
lot of things to do and why in the world
Gary it's not scalable it's not
sustainable
yeah you're making that face because
you're sewing our cocoon but like boy
just like like you know like they're
like don't do that it's not bad nobody
expects you to do it not at this scale
and you have a great culture and you
have great intent just do that I'm like
nope this thing matters to me
so micromanaging the hello into my
company three to six months in that a
lot of people outsource to an HR person
or the leadership so I do unscalable
things all the time micromanaging if I
deem them the most important pitching
new business I like to micromanage that
because it's important to win business
like money helps me keep doing
everything rule number nine don't make
excuses
Roberto asks what do you feel is a
bigger obstacle to success a lack of
time or lack of capital Roberto this is
a tremendous question I think the
biggest obstacle to success is a lack of
optimism that question in itself is the
problem my friend right you're looking
at two things that are both negatives
and guess what both of them are
obstacles when I started winelibrary.com
transformation from my business I had
time I've worked my face off every
minute but we didn't have a whole lot of
money in our profit Center so it took
more time right it's just the way it is
today I have more money but boy don't I
have time but neither ever ever will be
an excuse for me and so just add
willness through the throat of the
vaynernation
that's right I went that graphic don't
smile d-roc here's the bottom line I
refuse to allow you to get an answer to
that question because both of them are
firmly square in the excuse column and I
have no patience for that there will
always be problems let's talk about a
million other things that are a way to
stop success the health and well-being
of your family members so it takes your
mind away from execution the country you
live in government and political you
know concepts at these moments a la
startups in China that I've invested in
that got traction but then people that
were wired into the government decided
to not allow it to happen
the startup disappeared not as easy to
be an entrepreneur there it's still a
communist country sorry it just is and
so all these things can be problems
right there's a competitor with a
billion dollars who's also skilled and
punches you in the mouth and knocks you
out in the first round right the world
changing I mean there's just a million
obstacles right the media one bad
coverage of you a moment in time you
know what I think about a lot you know
what I think about a lot let's get
really real this is why we did this show
I always I'm a human being and I always
think about a moment in time what if I
just say the wrong thing at the wrong
time right what if I call out China for
being a communist country in an episode
while I'm on a rant and somebody who's
watching doesn't like the way that
tastes and it takes away a business
opportunity for me in China in seven
years even though I'm not trying to zing
it's just things that I saw what if what
if you know what if what if I look down
on my phone while I'm driving even
though I've really not done that and I
hit somebody and I kill them and that
becomes the story and I like forget
about the story about what you think of
me I will never recover from that
because I killed somebody because I
needed to check a tweet these are
moments in time so there are so many
things that can keep you from being
successful right the the people that you
invested in having something bad
happened to them so it slows you down my
friends there are a million reasons why
not
but there's one great reason why which
is you've just gotta persevere no matter
what it is it's just the way it is it's
hard being an entrepreneur it's hard
building a business everybody thinks
it's so easy that there's an entitlement
there's a disaster zinging China here
because my us thing right now there is
an insane generation of 18 to 25 year
olds right now that think they're
entitled to having a business because
they saw the social network movie and
everybody's decided if you're a kid and
you know what Tech is because you used
Instagram early on you're entitled to
actually build a business building a
business is hard and you know what makes
it really hard
everything that happens every day of
every moment so you can pick time you
can pick money as the one or two things
that you think stopped you from winning
your game but the
truth is there's a million reasons 99%
of businesses go out of business for a
reason and that reason is it's hard and
so if you're watching this show I've got
a sense of who you are and you need to
start creating layers and layers and
layers and layers of skin to be able to
get through because the glamour of being
an entrepreneur the goodness you know
you get very confused by my optimism
because it's my optimism I can't help it
it's just how I roll it's probably one
of the variable 1% reasons why I'm
successful but please don't get it
twisted this is hard every day is hard
and if you don't have the stomach to
weather the storm you will not be
successful and by the way let me throw
you a real weird curveball and that's
okay
people have to look themselves in a
mirror and understand if there are
number two three four five six seven in
an organization that has differences of
being a number one but maybe that's
where your skill set sits maybe that's
how you make your fortunes and Happiness
and all the things that you're looking
for and so that question got me going a
little bit Steve because it's similar
the context of excuses and I will never
make it excuse everything that's a
problem with me everything I don't
achieve everything that's a problem at
vaynermedia and everything is my fault
and I I succumbed to that and I respect
that and I actually think that's the way
it should be and so no excuses my
friends
rule number ten there is no overnight
success nothing in life is free nothing
happens overnight it all takes tons and
tons of work and tons and tons of talent
and tons and tons of serendipity but my
friends luck serendipity there's a
forced culture within that you know you
don't just sit in your room hoping and
then something lucky happens nobody just
knocks on your houses door and it says
congratulations you've been awarded this
luck comes from being in the right spot
I've been really lucky because I bleed
out of my eyes every day of my life and
work my face off get really lucky when
you have that 11:30 p.m. meeting where
the lucky thing happened pretty cool
since all you were sleeping I was pretty
lucky weird that I scheduled that
meeting because I did a ton of things
for 30 years that allowed me to even
have that meeting in the first place
that gave me the leverage to have that
lucky thing to happen
there's no overnight successes period
they don't exist show me
leave a comment YouTube leave the name
explain to me tell me show me let me
know
show me the overnight success because
I'll show you you justifying in your
brain something that is just not period
rule number 11 my personal favorite
believe what if I told you this was the
last Monday morning of your life what if
I told you you died this week would you
complain about your crap job or that
test you don't want to take I doubt it
you would go much higher level thinking
well that's really what it takes it
takes understanding that if you're not
pumped right now if you're begrudging
what you're about to do if you're if
you're not looking forward to it look I
respect practicality you got to go
through the school because your parents
want to you got to pay your rent you got
student loans I get it but please
recognize the world we're living in
we're living in a world where there's so
much more opportunity this internet
thing created way more opportunity for
all of us way more I mean look you only
not even be alive like your mom and dad
could have had sex like three minutes
later and you wouldn't even exist and
you're complaining you could have ended
up
three I just don't get the mentality of
being head down sad on a Monday morning
I'm gonna make Monday morning my [ __ ]
I'm gonna make you Saturday Monday
morning that's what I want to do every
morning and that's what I want from you
please take a step back and think about
how awesome it actually is and then
recognize that you can attack the world
in a totally different way because you
were lucky enough to be born during this
era rule number 12 don't dwell on
mistakes so many people come up to me
and say Gary it's so hard I look at
their Instagram and they're not posting
any of their content with hashtags which
is a by accident way to pick up exposure
in a world where they have no money when
you have no money when I took over my
dad's business it did three million
dollars a year 10% gross profit $300,000
before expenses my first year marketing
budget was $14,000 when you have no
money and I built that business from a
three to a sixty million dollar business
in five years I had to make every penny
perfect so I was right about email
marketing in 96 and I was right and
because of that I had 91% open rates
when Google AdWords came out the day it
came out I paid five cents a click for
words before anybody bid me up and I was
super right and that worked if it does
that lock versus preparation and do you
ever get anything wrong what do you do I
can make them as high I get everything
wrong it's just that I can't recall it
because once it's wrong I'm moving on to
the next thing
like dwell dwelling on what you've
dumped on is the quickest way for the
next thing not to work right yeah so
like so I think I do everything I mean
you know this this is a fun thing to say
some people in the back know this I was
a breakout YouTube star in the first
year 2006 I decided that the right
strategy was to leave YouTube completely
and go to viddler because viddler
offered me equity in their company and
I've left an enormous amount of
attention i deviated from my intention
thesis to do short-term economics and
equity in a company and I lost I lost
Wendy Brock finally came in my life two
years ago we started to try to build up
my youtube for the first time I was
sitting on 40,000 user followers in a
world where I could have had millions if
I just stayed the course so I make
mistakes all the time
I'm reorganize its based on a mistake I
made the prior year
I just don't give a [ __ ] about my
mistakes everybody else cares about your
mistakes if you're worried about your
own mistakes you've already lost rule
number 13 be pumped right now sometimes
a lot of people may try a new initiative
and then they don't get an immediate
reaction they and they think it's a
failure that's right
I want to watch your YouTube videos with
the Wine Library you know you had so
much content out there how did you stick
in there how did you keep yourself
motivated because I believe in my
strategies and I'm patient ish like all
great stuff especially when you're
innovating doesn't happen right away
this notion that like Oh Gary I tried it
I spent five hundred bucks on Facebook
Ads it doesn't work well what if your
video sucked what if your product and
service sucks I I tend to do things that
are very early that has been my career
you I when I do things I believe in them
I stick with them based on intuition
even though for 18 months nobody watched
my wine videos at all I knew it was
right I was right there's been things
I've done that I've jumped off of very
quickly I started gary v app V chat ve
like WeChat that was funny for my fans
great CRM one on one didn't feel right
after a week or two spend plenty money
building it knew it stopped it after you
know a couple months Wine Library TV
five years every day YouTube decided to
change it to daily grape insular app you
could buy stuff subscription for reviews
it was a lot of fun only did it for five
months stopped it because I didn't feel
right anymore it's always hard to know
when to jump off something new but I
find that people don't believe in what
they're doing they hear a guru and they
do it
begrudgingly because their boss wants
them to or they're like well Gary's
right a lot so let me do it but they
don't believe it and so then they jump
they're looking for knows instead of
yeses everything I do every business
development every event I do every time
I try new marketing tactics or sales
tactic I'm looking for the yes right I'm
looking for the yes and if the no
punches me will then on my crap then no
punched me I believe the majority of
people when they try new tactics are
looking for the no mm-hmm and you're
gonna getting a lot of subtle knows
immediately right and so I think that's
why that happens
rule number fourteen do what you love
you do care
out everything and it starts with
yourself look yourself in the mirror and
ask yourself what do I want to do every
day for the rest of my life do that I
promise you can monetize that if you
love Alf doing Alf blog you collect
Smurfs Smurfs it up whatever you need to
do do it so many people are talking
about I can't monetize I can't monetize
there's a billion seven-year-old douche
bags that are in control right now but
the number two person that 34 year old
lady she's gonna buy your she's gonna
put the advertising on your stuff it's
coming stop crying and just keep
hustling ruler 15 figure yourself out
I'm desperate for people to start
defining their hopes and dreams and
wants and needs on their terms not on
what I say I don't care if you want to
hustle 18 hours a day I really don't I
really really don't I don't care if you
want to buy the New York Jets I don't
care what you want or need you need to
care about what you wanted you can't
worry about what I'm saying you can't
worry about where your flavor of the
month is right maybe I'm your flavor of
the month right now maybe maybe maybe a
consistent flavor of the light is your
mom's point of view is your older
brother who's guided you with the wisdom
but wants you to be a lawyer but you
don't want to be a lawyer you want to be
as sweet as you wanna you want to take
the chance of being an entrepreneur or
the reverse or the reverse I know
reaches and loves entrepreneurship
behind me but I think as you see me all
the time talking about like
self-awareness are you want this is the
golden era for entrepreneurship people
ask me for selfies this will go away it
may not go away for me but it's gonna go
away like you know it's the
Entrepreneurship like a rap artist like
a baseball player like the heavyweight
nobody cares who the heavyweight
champion of the world is right now
nobody cares who's an active astronaut
but they surely did in 1969 and 1954 for
a heavyweight champ or you know they
change they change and it will always
change and it will continuously change
and right now
entrepreneurship is in this pedestal
that's having its moment and what I'm
fearful of is that you watch my videos
you see my Instagram quotes and what I
want to clarify for everybody is I hope
you understand I am NOT giving advice to
everybody the only advice I'd like to
give to everybody is to do you define
what your North Star is to understand
yourself understand what your work-life
balance
ambitions are how much what your
financial ambitions are what your life
challenges are the problems that you
want to try to solve and cure as we all
do as humans trying to climb those
different mountains in our lives what
makes you tick that is all that matters
don't do it you know I don't think daily
be
all these videos for you to be like me I
don't think anybody should be like me
boyo there are enormous amounts of
pressures and sacrifices that I
recognize are just not healthy or
valuable to anybody else but it's also
not healthy or valuable to me to do some
of the things that you want me to do
like it's not fun for me to work 9:00 to
5:00
like I will break I will be as equally
devastated as you would be to work till
midnight every day and so we just need a
call to action for everybody recognize
we have to stop judging everybody else
I'm not judging you
I'm creating content for you to use as a
barometer to try to figure out what you
like and what you don't like and I'm
trying to provide value do my words my
actions and my content to bring to
people to amplify their worlds and
that's really it
the clarification like I don't want
people to to be like me I don't want
people to do me I want people to do
themselves and they just have to start
with understanding themselves and not
trying to be like me in this moment or
that person the next moment that person
next moment the people that most willing
to leave themselves and figure
themselves
rule number 16 be good at your craft the
problem is if you the greatest hammer
and the greatest screwdriver and the
greatest wrench the greatest in front of
you if you don't use them properly you
will lose right if there's a nail that I
have to put in that ground but I take
the wrench and I hit it when the hammer
was right there it still comes down to
the practitioner mm-hm and you have to
be good at your craft and you have to
love your if you love sales if you don't
love it you have no chance because it's
so hard it's so painful there's so much
rejection right so those are the things
I think about
so technology's clear neighborhoods you
just said there that the person is
equally important and more important
right and go right I just apologize for
jumping in but let me make it perfectly
straight if I go play Roger Federer
right now in tennis and I have the
greatest tennis racket ever made like
from taken from the Mars is new like
resources right and he took a John
McEnroe 1974 tennis racket he would whip
my ass like I'm crushing sales people
that have every sales force every one of
your competitors 37 features upgraded
went to every pro conference watching
this I will beat their ass in sales
every day of the week your talent rule
number 17 go do
[Music]
that's truly where you couldn't get over
it and why by the way that's the same
answer for everybody in this room that's
what humans are good at we all fail
we've all failed like there by I my
parents haven't been killed my child I
mean there's people that have their
children die like could you imagine like
the ideal like I'm like listen
unfortunately or fortunately depends on
how one wants to look at it I'm a pretty
optimistic guy I lost three of my four
grandparents before I was really before
I knew them to before I was born in one
very early on like so you know it's easy
for me to be happy I'm like in the right
order the health and well-being of my
family and there's nothing even remotely
close to that not even not even remotely
people have gotten three much worse this
is why I'm trying to recall our
grandparents and our great-grandparents
people were persecuted and killed like I
just we not have real headaches you know
I don't know why I have this highly
emotional and then completely
unemotional part of me but I mix them
together to create the balance and
that's what works for me so of course
there's nothing that I couldn't get
upfront like every other human ever
besides somebody who now lives in some
weird cave that we don't know about you
know what I mean we were strong as we're
really strong we're just being sold that
we're not because there's a lot of money
a lot of money and telling us that we're
not pretty enough thin enough smart
enough good enough that I want to tell
you your basco douchey rule number 18
focus on the positives I've been feeling
a little bit unmotivated and I've been
feeling like I should be doing something
or I should be just I feel like I should
be pulled and like this is an unfeeling
uninspired basically that's my question
how do you get when you lose inspiration
and you lose motivation how do you
get it back I get it back by remembering
that he might die tomorrow that's true
so I'm inspired by practicality and
reality and the truth which is it is
ridiculously impossible to become a
human being I am one I have other good
things going for me as a human being and
I'm just grateful you your dwelling and
looking at what you don't have versus
looking at what you have if you actually
looked at what you had your health you
know living in America you know who the
heck knows what would be on your list if
you actually spend all your time looking
at that versus I don't have a million
dollars I'm not famous I don't have this
if you spend all your time on what you
have versus what you don't have you
would be the happiest girl on earth
rule number 19 don't care what others
have told I load my business on side
I'll take a gap you on troika logic
I don't know you well enough you know
you know what I mean yes which one do
you want to do I would like to try to
take a cup to you okay
well that's why you're not asking which
one will you do
I wouldn't take either I can't answer
that for you Peter's holding you back
you know what you want to do the only
reason you're not doing is because
they're scared of doing what you
actually want to do right are you scared
to do it cuz your parents won't like it
my parents actually support me okay so
what is curtailing not failing that
still being at the same place when my
friends are the next level huge mistake
you don't want the same thing your
friends want so why do you care what
they have kind of number one mistake so
many people make is they care about what
other people have what anybody has if I
have more if I less doesn't matter I
worry about myself the fact that you're
worrying about other people's
accomplishments is already a losing
formula you need to get rid of that
first then you can focus on yourself
thank you you understand
rule number twenty fight you know to be
great I think you have to fight and I
very much think that my success is a
product of some level of skill but I do
think I win because I outwork people I
really do believe that I do believe that
100% and I'm not sure that if my dad
didn't set that example that I'd even
have the ability to thinks one could
work that hard
the fact that I've been working 19 hours
a day every day for the last 20 years is
easy for me it's the only gear I do
right I was poor I sucked at school it
was the only gear I have you know I
think you need to recognize that um that
your biggest advantage is that you're
hungrier than your competitor
if you are not applying your one
advantage which is your work ethic and
the hours that you have to put into your
business well then you're gonna come up
short I sit here with enormous
assumptions around all of you that
you're just too soft
right that I think that you've had a
better and that that alone doesn't allow
you to somebody will come with the
counter cultural point of view and be
like Gary that's cool but I don't have
to work that hard because I'm working
smarter yeah me too I work hard and
smart
now why look there's a 12 hour 10 hour 8
hour 15 hour will work there you can
finish a lot of things that knows 18 12
nine hours or you can finish medium
amounts of things or lightweight things
people focus on too many small details
way too many people this room are gonna
spend the next 30 40 years of their
lives trying to check the boxes other
things that they're not as good at and
that you're gonna waste a lot of time in
news I highly recommend for all you
hustlers there's a lot of you there's a
lot of you that are always talking about
Barry I do work hard and you do you work
for 16 hours some people just don't have
the attention span or the capacity to
remember or like there's a lot of things
I can't learn I was very poor student
because the subject matter bored me and
if I was forced to become great at
understanding the great artists of the
20th century I'm in big trouble and so I
would tell people to bet on your
strengths you need
bet on your strengths and don't give a
[ __ ] about where you suck at and to put
themselves in a position to win with
their strengths because that is
absolutely the straightest line to
success greatness comes from adversity
and and looking the the challenge in the
eye and having the intestinal fortitude
to kind of to step up and go after it
[Music]
rule number 21 die on your own sword it
is far more fun to die on your sword
than to die on someone else's I'm
inspired YouTube we're gonna make this
the episode thing you'll get whatever
you want Tyler but this is the Corbett
you just saw it on stage that's just you
just saw it on stage dying on your sword
is better than dying on someone else's
so many of you are doing things making
decisions and navigating your lives
based on somebody else's thesis you're
doing it because you think it's the
right thing because your dad's telling
you it's the right thing you're doing
what you're doing right now cuz you're
pandering to your boss even though you
don't believe in it this is how it's
gonna play out you are doing things
right now yesterday you made a decision
that you don't believe in but you're
smart you did it because you know how
your company scores here's the problem
with disruption and innovation right now
you're being rewarded for being a yes
person and in 36 months you're gonna be
fired for being a yes person and you're
doing it because you just need the
security of your job I'm telling you
right now if you're watching this vlog
and you've got like that means you have
a certain DNA please I implore you
please die on your sword not somebody
else's if you're gonna lose it's much
more fun to lose based on what you
thought do you I mean do you know how
many of you are gonna lose on somebody
else's thesis it's gonna kill at you
it's gonna eat at you it's going to be
the worst feeling so please pause this
video right now and ask yourself am i
doing my because of me then you're good
whether you're winning or losing or am I
doing it because somebody else is
telling me it's the right way or I'm
subconsciously pandering to please
somebody or something because I need the
short-term stability figure that the gal
you know it and I know it you just need
to do something about it
rule number 22 choose positivity I
really think mindset is
and so you've got a really desiring any
positive about things a negative
nothing's am i thrilled that I have the
ability to do things about it to make
what I'm worried about better or my
crippled by there's like these seven
things like tomorrow I always choose
positivity I look at other people around
me it's not just about me that winning
they choose positivity I look at the
people around me that are not women that
are not pressing that are not advancing
their issues and negativity it's
stunningly binary it's stunningly black
and white and stunningly Maori this is
uh this is really up to you and filly to
be very honest to be very frank I think
the biggest impact up having is I'd be
that all the emails because I read about
that last night as well is uh is
shifting that mindset and getting people
into that
understand what they're in charge on
that end and hacking and trying to pour
out the negativity dump the negativity
and a positive dump a negativity
I'm a positivity world that's what I'm
pushing that's my agenda and and that's
why I think you feel the effects
and your partner loved one wrestler in
audience so many people get 49 comments
for the phenomenal the ones like they
spend their time on that one ruler at 23
create things you believe in the way I
do branding I sell so infrequently that
I think some of you that are watching me
the hardest core need to hear this which
is it's okay to sell especially if you
believe in something look if you believe
in what you're selling and that's what
I'm spending a lot of time on now trying
to spend more time on really getting to
a place where I really believe in stuff
instead of just passive not creating so
it wasn't selling because I didn't
believe you know and just letting
everything come to me but as I create
these you know events Vayner experiences
a lot of events very big on events
events are so valuable just watching the
four DS crew is value and like how it's
impacting their business for $10,000
right drag em and you see I know you get
the emails the wine club like $150 worth
one for fifty five bucks like I've just
locked in November's it's gonna make all
your Thanksgivings ridiculous the
conference $500 two-hour session that in
my stomping grounds good deal compared
to like other conferences that I speak
at but you're giving the wine for free
or you're getting the talk too free and
you're getting the wine so like I'm very
fascinated because I'm putting more
pressure on myself to create things that
I really believe in which then allows me
to sell more and I just think for a lot
of you selling the ask the right hook is
very difficult you're passive you like
the idea of like feeling good about like
giving out content this and that when
you believe in something you can sell it
and you should put more pressure on
yourself to create things that you
believe in biggest problem is so many of
you self you don't believe in you're
just doing it for the money you're gonna
lose
not I don't like rule number 24 get
feedback you may be thinking that I'm
watching the show but what I'm doing is
what I need to do which is I'm reading
your comments too I've set it for all
the new ones that are here the comments
are my oxygen I don't think people
understand how much qualitative feedback
you get from comments reading comments
watching the explore pages looking at
how you guys respond to my stuff and
others there's so many hours of
consumption you know I don't this is
where I don't consume shows and things
of that nature because I spend so much
time reading reading reading reading
reading your feedback you I as a
collective I consume you guys more than
you consume me and so I just highly
recommend when you have a small audience
like you read every one of those
comments you engage with every one of
those comments brick by brick by brick
eventually you can't reply to everybody
but like you can always read a lot I
mean I read I'm just reading all these
comments
rule number 25 have fun working you know
what I noticed the Marion I want your
opinion surest I I've noticed that every
idea that I've had whether is a drunk
kid or the podcasts or whatever it was
past the auks good they're all things
that I felt like would end up being
really fun to do and and so my kind of
philosophy I'm adopting now is like if
it's fun fun it's probably you know why
that happens
it's a it's a bigger macro situation
because it's fun you're willing to work
your face off and working your face off
is actually the gateway it's not the fun
the fun is the doorway that gets you to
put in the work that gets you the
results because d-roc loves filming like
the 24/7 nature of what he does is you
know is why so many kids want to film
into this but they don't want to it's
not fun enough for them you have to love
it the cost of entry now is you see
understand you have to love like for me
building brands whether it's my own
brand
Rand's for the people other things the
why it's so the only thing I give a [ __ ]
about that I'm willing to put in the
nineteen that it takes because the
problem is now with the internet like we
were just saying being the middleman and
everybody can play there's some kid in
Kansas City who's gonna put in the 19
right my dad put in 20 and I don't want
any I don't want any of you little
should take my now what's amazing is
though the biggest thing I didn't know
is that's some fun but there's so much
that all those little that are gonna put
in the nineteen are gonna get theirs too
and that makes me happy
yeah so I would say funds a great
gateway to fun is the precursor to
ridiculous amount of work which then
gets you there yeah right
rule number 26 be 100% accountable I
think when I get the praise it's what
the [ __ ] does that have to do with me
when I get [ __ ] on I'm like that's on me
and I'll fix it and I think those yeah
that was a I said it really quick but
it's accountability its accountability
the ownership when you suck and it's
passing on the credit and that's it
and that's me and that's my makeup and
that's why I'm winning in life that's
why I'm always gonna win because when
you're under sound accountable
and you know you're garbage they're 100%
accountable when there's an issue
and when you pass on the praise when
you're getting it
you become fundamentally undefeated
unbeatable I'm straight-up unbeatable
because my head will never get gassed up
enough ever when I'm getting it good and
and I'll never believe it's me and when
it's bad I'll never point the finger to
anybody else
boys finger pointers pointing everywhere
everybody pointing fingers pointing him
everywhere everybody's fault with
yourself country your environment
the parents school system loss and
circumstance of course and of course
there's tragedies and crimes and child
abuse and real bad stuff
nothing it's not real say for the 95% of
you it's a mighty something
perspective expected everything rounded
in my perspective
never too high never too low it's about
them when it's good it's about me when
it's bad that's me
that's what I got for you that's where
I'm at that's what mindset and I never
waver hundred percent we've had my bad
days
rule number 27 don't rest on your
laurels let me just talk to you guys
about why toys-r-us trip filing chapter
11 matters toys-r-us did two things over
the last couple decades that make no
sense one very early in the 2000s they
outsource themselves to Amazon they
didn't believe in the Internet 17 years
ago so that Amazon do their fulfillment
which started people getting used to
buying toys on the Internet through an
Amazon world but most importantly they
just didn't innovate you know and when
you don't innovate you die like you
could have made toys towards lost three
years ago could have created the
National Lego Championships and
everybody would be there was there was a
million they could have made slime
centers they could have they could be
killing it right now with their
locations but no they choose to just
like sell toys out of it and none of you
want to go there first of all you're
gonna go to Walmart and pick it up for
less money anyway while you pick up your
groceries anything else and if you even
want to leave your home and you don't
and so you'll go to Amazon and do it
that way or buy it from somebody's
YouTube channel link or you know
Instagram account it's just it's it's
the best example right now of like how
in trouble everybody is if they rest on
their laurels
you know if Toys R Us the dominant niche
retail leader of a humongous
multi-billion dollar category is
finished what do you think is gonna
happen over the next six years
rule number 28 know your customers you
have to reverse engineer who you're
trying to get to you know if your sales
person out there right now if you're
trying to get to me and so many of you
are I get 50 70 bulk emails bulk direct
messages bulk Twitter direct messages
Instagram business cards all sorts of
weird stuff sent in the mail I'm busy
I'm busy and like I'm just not
interested in you selling to me not
because I don't like you because I
respect the game it's because I'm just
busy
it's nothing personal so I think the
first thing you have to do is reverse
engineer the person you know because I'm
not in the market to buy anything I'm
gonna be tougher but if I need certain
software if I need something that's a
good time to attack right so I think the
number-one rule of sales people is to
listen no you
audience know what they did if you see
an M&A just happened if you see layoffs
just happening if you see one of their
come if I see Burger King doing
something I'm thinking what does
McDonald's think of R Us I think a lot
of you are doing things that are
directly in front of you numbers that
they put in front of you you're trying
to achieve that because you have a beach
house you want to buy or go on that
vacation sales is a funny game if you
work in a big company they manipulate
numbers to create your actions I believe
that the best salespeople are doing
things in a different way I think you
need to care about the customer for real
reverse-engineer them and give them what
they need rule number 29 develop a
winners mindset I put out a post about
you know stop blaming other people stop
right start blaming yourself leave in
comments right now it's super
fascinating of course you you know so my
whole thing is like blame myself for
everything of course there's other
things that people are doing right like
if somebody runs me over with a car
right now and they were drunk is that my
phone was their phone I get that you can
blame that other person I'm not so much
worried about the actuality of the event
talk about mindset Tyler when are people
that are stands the mindset the mindset
of blaming yourself allows you to do so
much more so when it's 8 out of 10 times
on you you're moving forward instead of
looking backwards sure the 2 out of 10
but if you just end that mindset it's
just winner mindset is it my mindset
everybody's taking every word I say so
practical yes I understand that there's
issues in the world like it wasn't your
fault that an earthquake like drill your
house I get it it's the mindset to me
I'd be like man I shouldn't live in
California I don't know like mindset it
helps you eight out of ten times and the
other two times you just deal with it
rule number thirty get your speed up
babban here is all bent out of shape he
just said today is rough to be very
frank with you vaynernation
I don't give a [ __ ] if Tyler or you
think today was rough because I had 17
meeting
he couldn't be a part of because I'm
actually running a business here I'm not
from some teenage beanie Bopper trying
to do a vlog or some influencer doing a
blob or some family that's open for some
free detergent because their blog I'm
working here to Tyler so sorry that your
video blog is rough but let me tell you
what's not rough what's not rough is
we're living through the great era of
ground shift in marketing and business
everybody in this amazing town of New
York City which is let me just tell you
everybody who's not here vibrant at
Tenet p.m. right now because 98 percent
of your cities are sleeping
everybody here is collective pants
because the ground is shifting
everything that our grandparents and
parents grew up with everything that we
knew tried-and-true the stable pillars
of media Commerce influence persuasion
the way we make decisions the things we
buy and how what is cool and what is not
is on halt
the world is on call and you know what
that means
hustlers the opportunity is obnoxious so
whether you're focusing on vlogs or
influencers or how to have Instagram
stories or how to create alexa voice
skills or how to create your own podcast
as you see i'm full committed till if
you are not following my podcast pissed
the way I call today the the sum up of
all my meetings today none of which you
just watched is that the earth is moving
there's instability in the foundation of
how it was which makes an innovator like
me really happy
and what suffocates all UB players
because you like it like it nice slow
and stable let it be very clear with
this ending rant that game is over and
the people that are gonna win over the
next five to seven years are gonna be
very comfortable and controlled chaos so
you better get your speed up you better
work harder you better work smarter you
better try things you better keep your
subjectiveness and your ego at the door
because that slows you down and it
doesn't make you do you better move
rule number 31 take life by its throat
just enough enough enough like living by
somebody else's rules is a humongous
mistake I just literally sat down with
five people under the age of twenty
seven and it's so refreshing it is so
refreshing if you have not jumped on the
bandwagon of doing exactly what the [ __ ]
you want to do which is skiing for the
next three years or working at a job
that's not what your parents want or
what society wants this video is just
called enough enough make this little in
one two minute video depends on when I
finish the piece of content that gets
you to stand up and take life by its
throat do something stopping scared stop
letting the way you were raised the fear
as an offense take that away let me be
the person I'll take the blame
I loved that some of my employees are
like my parents don't love what you're
saying good parents because if you are
playing defense and if you are living a
life where your kids lives are the way
you're being fulfilled you're a loser
parents and so enough enough parents
imposing their way you want your kids to
be happy on your terms enough the kid
that's sitting right now in a desk and
saw this in a feed and you hate your job
enough stand up get out of here and do
you live your life you've got one life
do something about it
rule number two value do you really
think that was a good idea I know bro I
honestly think that that was one of like
the worst moves I've ever seen because
[Applause]
I'm not trying to razz you either I am
talking I'm trying to give you love I
love the passion to win the problem is
you tried to close on the first move you
brought them no value and you asked them
to bring you value like you gave like I
will stand up here and give a load of
value and never mention one time for any
of them to follow me and a lot more of
them will follow me then they're gonna
follow that bull move that you just did
I get it I get it but this was back to
the question that just happened this is
why I want you to win that move is
always gonna lose you can't go tonight
when you go out in Vegas and you see a
pretty girl at the bar you can't go up
to her and the opening move is like
here's my key let's go but that's what
you just did let them hold it but that's
what you just did to this audience with
business I mean because doing the right
thing is the right thing
karma is practical you know I heard
somebody rant earlier right that's like
hey when I win I don't think it's coming
out of you the guy that closed I
couldn't know who was on stage but I
believe in that right because I love the
idea of 85 people here going and
listening to me winning I didn't make
anything for it but it then becomes
brand if she goes down and listens and
then two years later she's having dinner
with a friend and she's talking about
what happened to her life that friend
might be the CEO of GE you know I'm
playing with the biggest brands in the
world I'm not trying to monetize my
audience I'm trying to like just bring
the most value in the world and let that
lift all my other opportunities so I
think I think giving away your best
secrets is the greatest strategy for two
reasons karma is practical and leads to
more business but here's the secret and
it's even funnier 99% of these people
are not going to do anything about it
the read somewhere about five or six
years ago I realized this fact holy
people aren't gonna do anything with
this so like there's still gonna be
plenty for me and I'm gonna be the most
lovable guy ever I love this rule number
33 be ambitious my success is that I
prefer change I'm comfortable and change
and I realize change is the only thing
that allows you to win in the long term
the 98% of the human race and maybe
hired doesn't like it we are having a
macro change
we're having a societal change you know
like I'll be honest with you I'm like
ambitious and realistic one of the
biggest reasons I kind of went even
harder core at my personal brand like 15
months ago like back to what's worked
for us which is like hey here's my
example at least it's something to hold
I was like yeah I'm gonna make myself
the most famous person in America on
this fishery and then it'll be
undeniable and by the way it's working
I'm really good at underpriced attention
and culture I really am you know it's so
funny you start realizing your life so I
was good at baseball cards I decided
Frank Thomas and Kenny Lofton we're
gonna be better than most people thought
so I just brought a lot of rookie cards
for underpriced costs and I was right
but what I'm really great at is I
understand consumer behavior and
attention just fast enough and earlier
than most people and I've got an uncanny
ability of that let me build a machine
around that that's over the last nine
years I've built a company called Manor
media we're 200 million-dollar company
in revenue with no funding that does
agency work and we own a female
publishing company like a refinery29 and
my ambition is to build out the
communication Deathstar to deploy it
against my personal brand the
nonprofit's I care about but ultimately
my goal
by the New York Jets in a way I think
I'm gonna do that is I'm gonna buy
iconic brands and things that mattered
in the world that are gonna get over the
next decade
and then I'm going to rebrand them and
run them through my machine and so I you
know I'm building this huge agency media
company that is really just a front and
a proxy for my long-term ambitions
it just it pleads underpriced attention
and culture more efficiently than I
think any other machine out there right
now and that's why cool things are
happening for me
rule number 34 seize the opportunity you
weren't born into a rich family you're
the wrong skin tone you're this you're
that I get it but just they've got the
we got to get back you got that you won
a lot though you want it you've got to
get back do something with it especially
now
your grandparents didn't have this the
Internet is crazy it just is it just is
and so why do you think everybody's
getting out in now because three old
white guys don't control the media
anymore the do you think is happening
here this is the greatest fear ever for
anybody the market the platform is the
Internet this is unbelievable
unprecedented times we will look back at
this 200 years from now like these had a
good opportunity this is buying
realistic do somebody bought the land
that we're on right now for $1 at one
point that's what's happening with us on
the internet the attention of the end
consumer is cheap right now you can grab
it around whatever you want to be about
and it doesn't cost you anything other
than your time and so many of you are
complaining but then are too fancy to
put in the 15 hours a day to get it I
got no respect for that I got no respect
for anybody who complains and isn't
putting him to work because it's an
excuse to not do
rule number 35 get experience you've got
a try stop
the biggest reason you don't know what
you want to do is you haven't tasted
enough things and the biggest reason
you're not tasting enough things is
you're worried about finding it too fast
start with the finish line all right too
many people are just worried about
tomorrow go backwards from what you want
to achieve financially and in your
legacy and then make all your behavior
every day map to your finish line
the way that it can that a 20 year old
can make the world better twenty or
thirty years down the line is by making
themselves better first I think I think
people don't realize that the way to be
selfless is to be selfish it's very hard
to change the world if you're not good
to me when I look around this many
people being in their 20s like
everybody's judging themselves way too
early what I would do is gather as many
experiences as possible you know you're
not lost in life they're just early in
the process
rule number 36 get attention there is
ridiculous confusion in the system I am
winning and will win at all time levels
get ready you will tell your grandkids
that you once saw me live like I mean
that and by the way it's not because by
the way I don't by the way real quick
cuz I don't want claps for that I need
you to understand how I think about that
it's not because I think I'm fancy or
great I think it's because I'm very
common simple about one simple tiny
thing underpriced the tension it's so
grossly underpriced I'm asking you let
me tell you the story about MTV when MTV
came out in the early to mid 80s how
many people remember when MTV was
launched when empty when MTV was
launched the biggest bands in the world
the biggest bands in the world got
together for a dinner that one of their
managers told me about and decided that
they would not make music videos for MTV
because that was giving away music for
free that why would we spend money to
make a video put it on MTV but when
that's giving people the music for free
and they will not go out and buy the
record at the same token up in
humming artists Madonna Duran Duran and
on and on understood that it was where
all the attention of the youth was and
it was a gateway drug to the sale they
understood that MTV was a jab not the
right hook Facebook and Instagram at
this second is the most underpriced
scaled jab in the history of marketing
except for one other moment from 2001 to
2005 Google AdWords was a ridiculously
under priced jab how many people here
took advantage of Google 2001 to 2005
raise your hands so for you you really
know that's how I did it
Wine Library had no money but when
you're buying people who want to buy
wine for five and ten cents a click it
works out real fast when it's that
underpriced one company one company
during that time acted the way I'm
aspiring to act right now as Gary
Vaynerchuk on social media one company
from 2001 to 2005 spent enough to
justify how underpriced it was that
company was a small book company called
Amazon Amazon as you all know now is the
company of our world it will win
everything it hasn't even begun
literally the only thing that will stop
Amazon is antitrust government
involvement otherwise it will destroy
everything
it got its fuel from Google 2001 to 2005
that occurrence is happening right now
on Facebook and Instagram and we're not
squeezing the juice out of that fruit
anywhere close at least we have picked
up the fruit rule number 37 ignore the
opinions of others on a bigger macro
patience and failure they all ladder up
to one thing which is insecurity the
reason people don't put themselves in a
position to fail the reason people
aren't patient is they value other
people's opinions too much which then
dictates their behavior which then gets
into all of this why is this if you like
don't hold on to it and with the thought
of in case it fails because you just
need to realize it's your Scarlet Letter
literally the reason people are scared
always is the outside force having a
failing business and everyone's like I
see you could never do or whatever the
cliche is right yeah it just doesn't
matter you know why so that's one piece
and even if it didn't succeed what
there's such better people like what I'm
such a better person than other people
because I can build a business that's
[ __ ]
rule number 38 change your environment
I'm getting more and more intrigued by
mindset because I used to think of it as
fluffy like self-help and now I think it
more as strategy what's your strategy in
life somebody asked me on Instagram
after I posted a scary if the mindset
has been skewed how can you bring it
back and I answered with by surrounding
yourself with people who have the
mindset you aspire to my friends please
understand that mindset is controllable
in the same way that all our opinions
are controllable the key is to add more
people with optimism and cut people with
negativity it's very very simple now
it's very hard to cut people with
pessimism cynicism and negativity when
they are the people that are the closest
to you parents siblings spouse but the
bottom line is if you're asking the
question I'm gonna give you the answer
the answer is add more people with
positivity and optimism and cut people
with pessimism and cynicism who you
surround yourself matters what content
you consume matters I basically
suffocate myself for a long period of my
time and created an environment that was
based on offense and optimism and now I
know no different please do the same for
you make that move mold and I mean mold
your mindset by
what you consume and with whom you
consume it I would argue that well more
than 50% of the people in this audience
are here today because they worry about
the way they would be judged by one and
or two family members in their you know
seven eight people circle if you're not
feeling it find new friends I'm being
dead serious about this this one is real
big for me who you hang out with is a
huge Yannick and these are all trying
true things right we've heard the you're
the whatever of the five friends you
spent like that's real and one new
winner friend like you know what I mean
I had one new winner friend and cut one
loser friend like yeah I know he's been
your boy since fourth grade but he sits
at home and smokes weed and plays 2k all
day like you can only love him so much
rule number 39 go all-in I know that if
I can suffocate all of you today to take
25% of your take-home income this year
and pour it back into two people who do
video and written word and put it into
Facebook and Instagram ads literally all
of you will email me 24 months actually
get if you can start right away
literally 25% of you are going to come
to me this time next year right here and
be like holy I've been listening to your
stuff for seven years your keynote was
different in Miami last year at this
time I listened I said it I don't need
to go to Ibiza three times this year yet
I don't need to buy a better BMW this
year to make me feel good with the
neighbors get I don't need another pair
of Supremes or Yeezys I took the money
and I put it into Karen the film woman
and Rick the ad guy and now my business
is 2x this will 100% work even if you
suck
on camera have zero charisma are only
eight days in the industry this will
work because it is such under priced
attention that the ROI will work that if
you're a to in skill the ads are a
twenty in the ten point scale and it
closes the Delta of you being average if
you literally literally and I've said
this for seven years if you literally
literally go interview the guy who owns
the gym in town the guy who owns the
pizza shop the woman that owns the
insurance brokerage if you literally
literally literally just interview your
local community that you become the
local newspaper in three minute video
form on your phone you don't even need
to hire B rock or babban drives your
phone if you literally take it selfie it
and interview the principal of the
school in your neighborhood you will
become the local celebrity who can then
transact on whatever you're trying to
sell that group if you bring value to
people if you interview the best high
school basketball player literally just
that your business will change or if you
literally just give the advice of how
you got here what you learned if you
shared your thoughts if you do not
understand that you were a media company
that you will not be as successful as
you are today in a decade and that's not
interesting when the alternative is your
four to seven times making this thick
guys you have to understand what
happened to Blockbuster and Netflix what
happened with uber and taxi cut
companies what happened with hotels
versus Airbnb is happening with you as a
human in your business and so when you
have the best hand and you know it
because you've been paying attention and
you know how to play poker you go all-in
everybody here is playing Facebook
Instagram social media YouTube
podcasting like they have the best hand
and they're calling and you're not going
them into getting all the money you're
just folding and that's this audience so
can you imagine what I feel is going on
outside the stadium
so this is a call to action for
everybody to do me one favor and I do
think I can get a lot of you to do it
which excites the [ __ ] out of me please
right now listen maybe you've laid out
money maybe you're in the middle of a
renovation maybe you're paying for your
kids college
Mazel Tov I know there's nuances on
everybody's life but if you are in a
position where literally your take-home
income this year is literally the stuff
you're gonna go and do things with
please from 25% to 90% if you can go
humble please take that money and hire
two people to make a lot more content
for you about you and your business and
please give the rest of the money to
Facebook and YouTube and Instagram and I
fundamentally promise you you will walk
here to this conference next year and
personally thank me emotionally because
your business will change and I know not
one of you has gone all-in rule number
forty love your audience
you know else when you do a face hey
James its Gary Vee I'm here with your
dad I'm really pissed that you're not
here but I respect that you're hustling
that's exactly what you should be doing
hope we get to be see it thank you
rule number 41 go on the offense the
biggest reason people aren't happy right
now is because they value somebody
else's opinion more than they value
their own that is the number one blanket
statement that I've got for everybody
you're your mother's point of view on
you
your wife's point of view on you you're
your boyfriend's point of view your
homies point of view it like the reason
I'm super happy is nobody can tell me
nothing my wife mom and daughter could
walk into my room right now tell me I'm
a piece of crap and I would be 100
percent on things that is some gangster
emotional structure and that's why I can
never use I Know Who I am and I just am
unfazed so if my mom daughter and wife
could come in and tell me I'm a piece of
crap and I'm cool what do you think that
troll on Instagram that says I suck does
nothing so you need to figure out the
following it is very likely that either
your mom or dad screwed you up they made
you insecure they didn't love you enough
they told you they you aren't good
because they weren't good and misery
loves company once you face that demon
once you cut out negativity and the
people that hold you down and you
surround yourself with positivity and
don't confuse delusion don't watch my
videos and rah rah up and you don't put
any work in nothing Goods gonna happen
you're just gonna watch my videos so
don't get it confused but life is basic
you're either on the optimism team or
you're on the pessimism team your other
you're either on the offense or you're
on the defense the reason people are
unhappy is because let's talk about
money and unhappiness your three best
friends have a BMW and you don't you
think it's that you don't realize that I
loved when all my friends had BMWs and I
nothing it's just perspective man what
are we doing here like what are you
valuing like what was everybody's on
defense all the immigration issues in
the world nobody's taking yours any
think some immigrants taking your job
you suck
like if you think that right do you
think somebody else is taking your spot
this is the world we live in the rich it
like you don't rich this world in the UK
market you live in the UK and you're
complaining get the hell out of here
so so that's practical you you have a
family member or a childhood that put
you in a mindset of defense and listen I
know I'm gonna get a lot of hits on
Twitter and Instagram about this
interview now when I spit this because I
know a lot of people haven't heard of me
or to have context I mean let me just
say this the answer to everything is and
what now right like I know people grew
up in alcoholic households I know people
were molested
I know people had somebody steal all
their money here's my problem
nobody cares like what are you waiting
for
like like nobody's there is no fair
fairy flying down from the earth and
saying you were born an African American
in America where that's an issue here's
a million dollar it's not happening so
my thing is instead of dwelling and
wishing how it was understand back to
the next practical part of your question
that the Internet is now here and guess
what the Internet's not a 76 year old
white man it's the Internet and that
means everybody's got a shot so go take
yours it's happening on YouTube Facebook
Instagram go figure it out instead of
shooting on it and thinking it sucks and
go get your money happiness and that's
it simple as that I got no time for
people complaining because it's just not
clean anymore 1986 yes 2018 what do you
think's going why do you think me too is
happening now the Internet one it's over
go get yours rule number 42 fall in love
with the game what do you think the
minimum amount of money you want to make
for your life like like like what would
be the minimum amount money that you
make every year that allowed you to live
and do that content Mediasite what do
you think great so you're like what is
amazing about that if that's where
you're at
well then at this young of an age and
well that's where you're at and the fact
that you're even here and you know it's
just unbelievable amounts of content in
written audio and visual form on
Instagram snapchat Facebook Twitter and
YouTube and podcast and I will tell you
I would be flabbergasted in three four
or five six years unless you suck which
you may but if you don't suck and you
have that little of a financial need
right which is remarkable which is the
biggest thing something here I don't
know if they're here said you made me
realize I didn't need Rolexes and things
of that nature right like the biggest
reason so many of you will fail is your
number for success is far greater than
his you think you need a million which
will then mean that you're gonna do a
lot of things when you don't get a
million very quickly that won't ever get
you a million so if you if you think
what I just said is cool which is bleed
for six years in a row
you'll probably get sponsorship or sales
of product to 40,000 a year to me that's
what I did I knew what I wanted I was
willing to give up my 20s for it gave
him up gave him up you know somebody
said it's difficult not to document
right now I'm like but I but I didn't
write but like what should I build my
business or should I document I'm like
both he's like well I gotta pick one I'm
like build your business like so if
you're if your ambitions are that humble
which they are that's incredible that
excites me because by the way here's the
funny part
that's what I was too I just needed a
hundred thousand a year just that seemed
rich to me right like I was like cool
I'll be okay like like I'll have a house
like you know it's not you know I just
needed to play much I needed the game
and too many people too many of you in
here want the stuff not the game when
you fall in love with the game
everything's different because you've
already won that's real it sounds cliche
but it's real ruler 43
look for positivity you find what you're
looking for I've been giving a lot of
thought to kind of just watching what
I'm seeing out there in the social
digital ecosystem and very honestly just
real life and I'm watching so many
people over the last two to three years
look for negativity look for something
that's wrong find where people disagree
with them fight look for what was me
downside the half glass empty and and
then I go to a Twitter search or look
around the world and I find ridiculously
beautiful things every day every day
thousands of kind acts randomly by
people all people that I have
conversations with who see the
opportunities whether it's in business
like voice and AR or crypto or whatever
it may be just this amazingly
interesting thing that I feel the
majority of you are looking for the
wrong while there's plenty of wrong and
plenty of right in the world it comes
down to one very simple thing what are
you choosing to look for because I
promise you if you right now and I'm
making this video for one reason 24
hours of trying to find the good
somebody saves a kid somebody opens the
door somebody does a nice thing for you
bit somebody system Thank You 24 hours
of looking for positivity could change
your life
honestly making this for one person's
one one person watches this video
chooses to do 24 hours of looking for
good instead of looking for bad and
their game changes d-roc heard somebody
at a convenience store saying mom you're
always so negative you're always so
negative I am blown away by the fact
that life gets real simple if you break
down into this are you looking for the
negative this sucks this government
sucks this person sucks this is or
you're looking for the positive she's
nice that's remarkable I've got this
opportunity you choose what you're
looking for because what you look for
you find that's how life works
rule number 44 make no excuses I know
you helped a lot of people start
especially younger people but how does a
person with four kids yes him right now
doesn't like his job yeah but just can't
quit and sell stuff yeah and find stuff
in a junkyard so if you're listening and
you're over 42 let's
she's my age there's something
interesting you said something that I
helped a lot of people that are younger
it only has to do with one thing they
actually believe in the technology we
live in right this room is filled with
guys right now who've taken advantage of
YouTube or Instagram or just the
Facebook's of the world and the only
thing I need to do to break through
somebody who's 47 in the suburbs of
London who has a mortgage debt and three
children is for them to understand that
unlike when he or she and I grew up and
there was no internet the thought of
like having a happy life was separate
than taking care of what you were
supposed to take care of the fact that
everybody can come home tonight at 6 7 8
9 p.m. and then take out their phone or
their iPad or whatever and get to work
for 3 more hours and go to sleep at
midnight get their good six or seven
hours of sleep I'm not talking about
don't sleep a lot of people get me
confused my big thing is if you're not
happy if you're happy and you make
37,000 pounds a year Mazel Tov do you
but if you are not happy if you hate
your job right you can do something
about it instead of blaming brexit or
blaming Trump or blaming your mom like
do something about it and my point is
it's the Internet rule number 45 blame
yourself today
yeah I like it I like it I like it
I'll tell you why because I even I can
tell by your demeanor that you're gonna
be okay
the fact that you realize that that
negative moment has positive impact the
question is why did it happen and that's
what you have to be honest with yourself
I don't know you know but that's you
know I'm pumped that you can have the I
mean you're more positive and half the
people here and it sounds like you're
having a terrible day
super-race that's why I want to ask you
how do you keep the positivity the
calmness when everything is because
basically when things happen I go the
other way so tonight I just was
reminding myself every time I in every
time you came and next person came I'm
just reminding my little e in my own
head saying you don't mean I said to one
of you I said they said how do you stay
humble when you're so successful I'm
like because I know if I die tomorrow
I'll have a good day on social media
like most comments ever on my latest
post on Instagram I never goodies to be
like off that was the last one weird and
and I know that all of you will be on
with your life a week later you have to
balance your ego with humility in the
same way when I'm having my worst day I
realize I'm the best I'm gonna be the
best that ever does this and so the way
I handle things is when something's
going one way I use all my emotional
strength to push the other way what are
you gonna cry for us your life cuz the
conference comes up like I just like to
me it's just like look what the guys if
you're in this room right now let me
just remind you that there are seven
point seven billion people literally
right now as we stand here there are
women being shipped to be strippers in
parts of our world right now as we stand
here there are women who are basically
caged mentally usually and are being
shipped to dance on a pole in Manhattan
and in London like do you understand
what's good there's there's genocide
going on right now like what do you
think's going on like we lack
perspective your conference got that
boohoo I lost a client boohoo there's
people dying out there like like so when
Americans or Europeans talk to me about
race or gender I'm sad it's the real
life but I remind them because it's a
positive thing cool but let me tell you
about the person that's ranked seven
billion in the world they have it bad
and so I just I struggle like I want to
write like I listen I'm weird and I
think about
things like animals like I don't know
like if you're the best elephant
we are still better than you like you
know like without really listen you know
I got hot on this about a year ago the
400 trillion to one it's impossible to
be a human being you one I don't know
how to get upset after that I keep
perspective right like you're gonna
learn from this you forgot I promise you
it's failing cuz you and and when you
start owning your SH and not blaming
other people and yeah I think this is
the kick I've been on lately on
Instagram right like blame yourself you
know why I'm always happy I blame myself
when you blame yourself for real you're
gonna always be happy because you don't
feel like somebody else controls you
rule number 46 find your why my big
ambition is to be an all time
entrepreneur by both my success in my
career but what has become more evident
to people I think recently is also by
influencing as many people as possible
in a positive way so that they get
theirs and that means the person that
goes from the job that they're not
excited about to making eighty four you
know thousand sterling a year being
happy talking about their proper
football team on Instagram and YouTube
to the young gal right now in Sweden
who's gonna start up 500 million dollar
you know media company so I think to be
the great entrepreneur of this
generation there's clearly the bezos's
and and the Elon Musk's and the sucks I
don't think I'm gonna be able to create
that kind of wealth
I just want to create obnoxious amount
of wealth
but you know a billion dollars in a
billion people I think puts you above
everybody else and and I think that is
where my behavior is right now like why
am i doing this podcast
rule number 47 live without regrets but
veinous booze new media yeah the book
yes she's podcast yes you do a lot yeah
man look here's what I think I think we
get one at bat um the number one thing
that scares me in life is regret I
really really really don't want to be on
my deathbed whether that's tomorrow or
when I'm 97 and think I should have done
that I should like that's that spooks me
right like hard work people judging me
leaving you know trolling me on social
media like all the stuff that normal
people worry about
I don't worry about I worry about regret
and so I'm trying to squeeze everything
out of my life and so yeah I do a lot
rule number 48 hustle Thunder price
attention my religion my religion to
many of you in here have ego around your
time when it's the only thing you got so
the reason I always know is because I
work because I work I work I try things
I test IDM you back I suite I dive work
so when you're inch you taste it and
when you've done it for 20 years
you see patterns Facebook's still
underpriced you just can't target 22 to
25 year old african-american fans of
football because other people are doing
that too now it's just like Google early
on you could just target soccer one-word
5 cents a click I did it
wine wine wine but then I had to put at
the end of the game now I got to put
2013 you know Heller cellars Zinfandel
like long tail real estate if you're
right about London look it's my
favorites do you know what you
understand that somebody once bought
this building for $1
somebody bought the land we're on for a
dollar once that happened it's a long
time ago how do you know you're a
practitioner the reason I do is to how I
learned you got to put up all of you
were like well I can't do podcasting and
Facebook and Twitter oh but I can't I
can blog but I can't why if you want it
so bad my thing is why if you want it so
bad like if you want to have a media
company around Caribbean food culture
why can't you I wanna you know what I
want to see I want to see all your
minutes I want to see all your minutes I
want to give you d rock for today I want
to watch you from the moment you wake up
to the moment you go to sleep let me
promise you something you're gonna get
exposed there so so that's why dailyvee
happened because you guys were like a
lot of you didn't know me before daily B
how many people knew me before dailyvee
well not bad right you got you got to
really know me post dailyvee you heard
hard work and hustle before you were
confused and I've been doing that every
day for 20 years rule number 49 maximize
your strengths like I wasn't born six
foot seven and can run like a cheetah I
couldn't wish I was something or I can
realize I am something and try to
maximise on that it's a game of poker
you get a hand
nobody's gonna cry for you about your
hand nobody's gonna say oh it's terrible
that you're not fast or tall or gorgeous
of telly or or can sing if is what it is
and now the old
that can happen is you can figure out
how to navigate it the second you stop
dwelling and a second you stop start
doing everything changes they don't give
up the second you understand that and
just start trying to make happen with
that energy
you win and rule number 50 the last one
before a very special bonus clip is get
Authority
I want to be and I want to say in their
conflict and finding that every time I
mentioned that let's go you know you
want to do to life and I tell people
this their instant response it is you
know hiding to do that you're not
married
my parents are born as if I was eight of
them by eight I'm not married I can and
I can answer your question right away
we're gonna build it amazing yeah we're
gonna build an amazing case study
together I'm gonna give you I'm gonna
give you three names and then you're
gonna cruise into the sunset of success
which is let's figure out the three most
successful coaches in the history of
sport that everybody knows up that
didn't play that sport Bill Belichick
even though I hate him with all my guts
did not play football he grew up in the
football game
right his dad and what it was a coach
shouldn't have you but Bill Belichick
did not play football and he will
probably unfortunately go down as the
greatest or if not one of the greatest
head coaches of all time you don't have
to beat listen I think you have to be
people have to be thoughtful I hate
twenty two-year-old life coaches that
haven't lived life but if they if they
speak about here's my life experiences
and and why you can eliminate though
very quickly the art when somebody says
to you but how are you you can't do let
me first of all a couple other questions
are your friends and your circle telling
you you can't do that or are customers
that you're trying to do that with
telling you that they don't want to go
with you because you're not married no
this is more acquaintances are people
you know that I run into yeah so listen
that's a mistake
listen that's a mistake
like you can't listen to acquaintances
or opinions don't matter okay you can't
listen stone hat you do it anyway how do
you have I'm fine
no go ahead I'm sorry I'm getting
excited you should talk go mine's like
basically like I wanna because I follow
you and I was following it for a couple
years now and I do agree what you have
to say about education I do think people
are gonna start moving from you know
going to school is the favorite kids at
school to find I got your answer I've
got your answer a lot of people get up
of course I know I know exactly where
you're going so if you're not gonna get
the PhD there's only a few ways to
justify and gives confidence to the end
market what what why they would jump
with you it's crazy to me that so many
people I was watching 60 minutes last
night in the background as I was working
and the way that Oprah was justifying
the person was he has a PhD in this and
the masters in that the even 60 minutes
used those pieces of paper to create a
far authority in our society pieces of
paper from businesses and that's what
colleges are has been the authority the
only other people that get authority are
the people that have gone out and done
it and have people co-signing them right
make sense so the way and this is why I
love working for free when you don't
have a piece of paper right one of the
reasons I love working for free is
working for free for somebody who is
that person in society whether they got
a piece of paper or their Puff Daddy and
they just did it becomes the equity that
you trade under once you become great at
something right and gain Andy who's
sitting here right now every single
famous person I see gives him a lot of
street cred right away not because he
got a degree for personal branding and
marketing for Virginia Tech what degree
can you get the science not because of
his [ __ ] political science degree
from Virginia Tech but because he went
and worked underneath me and I went out
and did it and I always give him love
and good vibes the end it's not babiness
degree from the USC school and Fillmore
NYU
I jumped out you know right so what you
need to do it what you need to do is one
of two moves if you're not gonna go get
a PhD and have everybody comfortable
with it
you wouldn't need to go work for
somebody that is the authority and ask
all thousands of people that are
authorities and work for them or okay
you need to give your services for free
to five couples crush it for them and
use their word-of-mouth and endorsements
and as your leverage point the end
now I have a very special bonus clip
from garyvee on how to be real with
yourself but before that you've just sat
through a really long video we've done
five top ten rules of gary's who would
compiled them all into one mega video
for you i would love to know one what do
you think of this concept and two from
everything that you watched if you made
it all the way to this point what is a
single biggest piece of advice or the
biggest lesson that you learned that
you're going to apply somehow to your
life your business leave it in the
comments below when you write it down
it's much more likely to actually take
place and take hold in here thank you
guys so much for watching I believe in
you I hope you continue to believe in
yourself and whatever you're one where
it is
much love I'll see you soon and enjoy
the bonus clip
I feel like I've lost my hustle help
what do I do
Adam anybody who's losing their hustle
has a lot of variables and there's a lot
of variables in this episode this is the
variable episodes there's a lot of
context but it's not just direct answers
today
um listen you might have you might not
be passionate about your North Star
anymore I I've been going through
something let me actually break some
shattering news here for the first time
in my life I've been thinking about
weird things like sabbaticals and
building a business school in Haiti for
five years and like like I love listen
I'm still all about buying the New York
Jets and it's the process of that and
the game but it's amazing for me to be
in tune with myself the maturity like as
you get older like just dip like my kids
are six and three and they're
interesting like it's they're
interesting and like you start you know
I start projecting what do they look
like at 13 and 15 like if you're really
cool to like I don't believe in the
school system as much as everybody like
do I just take them and go do something
rogue like just different things like
you just evolved and and you might have
just lost your North Star the thing that
you thought you were going for might not
be it's why I was always happy that I
didn't want a million bucks
or they want fame or I didn't want a car
private plane or these little things
like it was fun to be like I want to buy
the Jets and what that always meant to
me is I want the process of buying the
Jets which means I get the hustle
forever because that's my that's who I
am maybe you've lost who you are or what
you want or maybe you've accomplished
kind of or maybe you feel it's
achievable I would be crushed if I
thought what I wanted to achieve was
super achievable I mean it happened to
me in the line is it's happening at
Vayner like as Vayner is becoming a
player in the agency world and we're not
like now we're like oh like and super
gonna be like oh like you know like like
that's not as fun for me I like being
the underdog
I like the climb you know I like that so
maybe that's happened maybe you're just
tired I mean I think one of the things
that the New York Jets do for me that
nobody understands is those hours
actually you just caught something on
dailyvee right me talking Jeff that was
the first time I talked business to a
Jets game in 15 years I looked at my
phone's the wrong time there's a very
big thing and only spent a second on it
like I am escaped and we're lacked and
by the way I didn't care about it like
that's how
like those three four hours of escapism
maybe need some vacation time maybe you
need to look at the people around you
maybe you need a change maybe you need
to break up with your boyfriend or
girlfriend like there's like there's a
lot of intense different things that can
be happening or maybe you can take a
step back and really listen to this
statement which is you've lost your
hustle because you've really are not in
tune to why you're doing it right you're
just not in tune to what you're doing it
that that that you're maturing and
realizing like a Ferrari or a fad watch
or courtside tickets or custom mics I
just wanted to show them you know is not
what you're living for and so you know
it's funny tonight I'm going to the
charity water gala I never thought of
myself ten years ago somebody who would
be so involved in nonprofits sitting on
the board of pencils of promise donating
I was you know I was old school in 40
I'm older like this was this new
narrative of much better people and
that's what I think you guys all are I
think you're much better generation I
grew up thinking I'll get rich and when
I'm old I'll be like giving out money
and doing that stuff so you just evolved
right and so maybe maybe you like me
like I haven't gone completely like I
don't have enough money like my kids can
give away all the money but I can't I
don't have that luxury yet but maybe you
want to do nonprofit maybe you want to
build schools for pencils of promise it
will take you a louse like maybe you've
lost your purpose so take a good step
back shut down shut down for 24 48 72
hours go away go away like this this is
how I want you to shut down go to Airbnb
this is a 2016 way to shut down go to
Airbnb find a very remote place you know
taught you have to go I'm taping stuff
yeah I'm just wrapping up the show sorry
go to go to Airbnb find a very remote
place that's you can get to at a low
cost like a crappy cabin far away on a
4-hour drive where you can like just
drive because you can or like somebody
will drive you there like hitchhike I
don't give a crap lowest cost farthest
away seclusion and just be with yourself
and start talking to yourself for real
for like really talk to yourself a real
one of the great things I do with myself
is I talk to myself for real you know
really nobody is a harsher critic and a
bigger fan of themselves than me and I
think that friction in both directions
matters
one was long the most important work
ever
if you had to think of one word that's
most important to you or that sums you
Apple that would be like a little beacon
pay believe nation if you want to know
what the most important one word is for
Tony Robbins
Gary Vaynerchuk Oprah Winfrey will.i.am
and Howard Schultz I have a very special
secret video for you check the
description for details
[Music]